[Musique]
Alexandre n'a que 5 ans mais il joue
déjà du Beethoven c'est le plus jeune
des 8 élèves venus d'Europe et d'Asie
pour une semaine de masterclass au
château de maison leur professeur n'est
autre que la violoniste est concertiste
de renommée internationale Violetta
smiley cuart
leur donner la possibilité de pouvoir
exercer leur instrument dans cette lieux
absolument sublime et à la fois aussi
d'offrir aux visiteurs de châteaux
d'entendre de la musique classique les
murs ils peuvent être absolument
somptueux quand on leur donne un peu de
son ça les rend plus égayé le lieu est
quand même fait pour la musique et cette
rencontre entre une artiste installé la
maison Lafitte des étudiants
internationaux et un au lieu du
patrimoine correspond tout à fait aux
objectifs de d'ouverture du patrimoine
sur la survivante que nous développons
au sein des monuments nationaux au sein
de ce superbe château du 17e le public
peut visiter la chambre du roi Louis XIV
le salon des captifs ou encore la salle
à manger du contre d'Artois tout en
profitant des mélodies de Bach Pablo de
sarazade ou frites Chrysler chaque
étudiant à son pupitre son violon
choisit l'endroit où il va avoir envie
de répéter et le professeur de
masterclass alterne soit des conseils
donnés en se déplaçant auprès de chaque
élève soit des moments de rassemblement
dans le grand salon il y a plein de
messages qu'on puisse transmettre en
fait avec les crains de l'archet quand
on les pose sur l'accord on arrive à
toucher l'âme de violon et si on le fait
vraiment magnifiquement bien on touche
l'âme de notre personnage qui est dans
la même pièce
une semaine qui fait partie du projet
musique sur la corde créée et dirigé par
Violetta huarts à la fois artistique et
pédagogique il donne la possibilité à de
jeunes violonistes de développer leur
talent et de se produire sur scène une
volonté de transmission chère aux yeux
de la violoniste à la fois en offre des
concerts qui sont d'une très belle
qualité et on donne des concerts des
jeunes avec lesquels on fait pour quel
on transmet tout simplement la musique
sur des conseils très pragmatiques et
sans une école qui est très bien fondée
et très clair pas à pas
un talent ne peut pas se développer
c'est un vrai engagement il faut
vraiment être très motivé parce que
c'est très intense l'idée c'est vraiment
d'avoir un challenge dans cette semaine
et dans un magnifique lieu c'est
vraiment magique parce que effectivement
on a l'impression d'être dans un monde
totalement coupé du mot pour clôturer la
semaine les 8 élèves et Violetta Huart
vont se produire samedi 13 et dimanche
14 à 15h dans la salle d'apparat les
deux concerts sont compris dans le
billet d'entrée
[Musique]